eight of the crash victims in Ethiopia
Ethiopia are Americans including Melvin
and Bennett riffle from Redding
California Melvin riffles wife Brittany
is expecting their first child others
who died include mouhot Hussain Abdullah
of st. Cloud Minnesota and army captain
Antoine Lewis of Madison Illinois who
was doing missionary work in Africa
Debora patta visited the crash site in
Ethiopia this morning good morning
behind me huge piles of dirt obscure a
massive crater which was caused when the
plane nose dived into the ground mangled
pieces of wreckage lie strewn across
this crash site which is now guarded by
local armed militia this huge crater
opened up when the Boeing 737 dropped
from the sky and ripped through the arid
wasteland below it's size and depth give
a sense of just how powerful the impact
was the two black box flight recorders
have been recovered from the wreckage
and will be the focus of the ongoing
investigation into why this plane went
down everywhere you go there is mangled
wreckage like this one and in amongst it
of a charred personal belongings a
reminder that so many people died in
this crash
in one area positions have been piled
into a large mound a tiny girl's purple
fairy princess dress many of those on
board this flight were young people who
simply wanted to change the world the UN
lost 21 staff members in the crash
people who work to improve the lives of
others in some of the most troubled
spots on earth crash site investigators
including a team of Americans will comb
this area searching for answers today
their job to piece together exactly what
happened in the six minutes after
takeoff that led to this devastating sea
for CBS this morning Debora patta at the
crash site in Ethiopia